okay what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don Saki on and
we are in a hot tub right now at dr.
Rick Doblin house the founder of maps
yeah it's great to have this meeting
with you Alan this is part of my office
I have had meetings here in the past my
office is just indoors a few feet away
but I just think this is a wonderful
opportunity for us to have this chat
exactly in a hot tub
it's we're more relaxed oh yeah it's
we're in Boston it's now approaching the
end of spring early summer it's really
nice out yeah Maps is the
multidisciplinary Association for
psychedelic studies you've been at it
for 32 yeah master started in 86 DEA
first tried to criminalize MDMA in 84
and so that's where I organized a group
of therapists and researchers to sue the
DEA to try to keep the therapeutic use
of MDMA available we won the DEA lawsuit
but the head of the DEA rejected the
recommendation then we sue them in the
appeals courts we want a couple times
eventually the DEA lawyers got smart
enough to figure out how to satisfy the
appeals court and keep MDMA illegal and
that's when I started maps in 86 because
it was clear the only way was going to
be through the FDA and through science
but it's really since 1972 when I
decided to focus my life on psychedelics
after having a lot of difficult LSD
trips and at 18 years old going through
the guidance counselor in my college new
college at Florida and saying there was
a different era I said I need some help
with my OST trips and the guidance
counselor was fine with that and he said
I'll help you and here's this book to
read and it was realms of the human
unconscious by Stan Grove yeah yeah
which who we've been in touch with to
come on the show as well oh he likes
that ups to need a touch on that as well
as this and then you your initial
research was in the oral use versus the
smoking use for cancer purposes for
being able to was it that was not your
control I can see chemotherapy yeah that
was my first research as a master's
student at Harvard at the Kennedy School
government yep but the first research I
ever did before was at my college which
was follow-up twenty five year follow-up
to the Good Friday experiment and so
that was one of the key experiments that
Timothy Leary was involved with at
Harvard can you teach us about that yeah
yeah yeah give us a little bit on that
yeah the Good Friday experiment is
phenomenal so it took place in 1962 a
fellow named Walter panky was a minister
and a doctor and going for PhD and
Timothy there was his PhD advisor and
what had been happening with all this
Huxley and other people they'd been
rediscovering psilocybin and other
psychedelics and learning about their
religious use for thousands of years and
people had a lot of spiritual
experiences from loss detail so they
decided to do an experiment to see if
psychedelics can produce mystical
experiences and to give you a sense of
how non-controversial this was this took
place in Boston University Chapel on
Good Friday and the minister was Howard
Thurman who was one of the most dynamic
black preachers in America and he was
the mentor of Martin Luther King was
Martin Luther King got a PhD at Boston
University years before that and so he
permitted this to be done so the
experiment was basically twenty divinity
students all-male from Andover Newton
Theological Seminary and they went into
church for about a three and a four hour
service on Good Friday and beforehand
before the service began everybody got a
pill and half was gonna be a placebo
they didn't know what was gonna be in it
it turned out nicotinic acid acid which
gives you kind of a hot flush but makes
you think something's happening and
psilocybin and so what was the dose the
dose was thirty milligrams so it was a
hefty dose in psilocybin synthetic
psilocybin synthetic oh yeah and so what
what had happened beforehand is Walter
panky had spent like a year or so
looking at the mystical literature from
all over the world from different
religions and he decided to try to
create a questionnaire about the essence
of the mystical experience across
different religion
so even though this was christened
divinity students in Chapel on Good
Friday it didn't have a single question
about Jesus it was more about the
abstract elements of a mystical
experience which is the sense of unity a
sense of connection everything's
connected that's divided into internal
unity and external unity yeah externals
sort of in the world outline internally
talk about that so much on the show the
importance of finding the inner
management within you and the inner
divinity within yeah and then also the
external oneness we talk about that so
much and that collective consciousness
of planet Earth orbiting the star and
how to work together how to prosper
together so it's so important that we've
had experiments like this over time to
help figure this out and that we're
going in this direction yeah and the way
the experiment worked I mean there's
other aspects of it a transcendence of
time and space a sense of something
sacred or holy deeply felt positive mood
the fact that it's transitory
paradoxical ineffable that you can't
really put it into words it's sort of
pre verbal yeah it's something that just
words are condensing they're not really
capturing the full experience yeah
and so the oh my god how do you describe
the feeling of oneness with words
it's internally and externally but this
is an experimental - of this
questionnaire that has been used all the
way up til today from 1962 it's been
slightly modified and it has been used
in the psilocybin research in the OSD
research we just finished in Switzerland
so it's still being used this
questionnaire is to be used yeah it's
for and after well no it's a description
so it's it's more a description of an
experience so you write that you fill
out the questionnaire so it's a
numerical okay and that you have to
technically have a 60% or more they have
a full mystical experience okay on all
these different dimensions mm-hmm and so
what he it was an idea of the questions
like yeah did you feel like you were
beyond time
you know did you feel that everything is
connected in the universe he you know
did you feel that that words would not
be able to describe this mm-hmm and
there's multiple different questions for
each category and in the end what was
discovered was that nine out of the 20
people had a mystical experience and
eight out of those nine had the
psilocybin awesome and so it was
validating this idea that psychedelics
which have been used for thousands of
years but now in a scientific context
could produce the spiritual mystical
experiences yeah
sigelei 262 now Walter Pankey who did
the study then went on to be one of the
premier psychedelic researchers with LSD
and psilocybin he went to work with Stan
Grof and Spring Grove Hospital in
Maryland and then he tragically died in
a scuba diving accident in 1971 and so
when I started college in 71 took a
bunch LSD you know dropped out in 72 and
I dropped out for ten years always
knowing I wanted to study psychedelics
but I didn't know exactly where or how
or anything like that so it took me 10
years to come back to college so in 82 I
started and I wanted to do the new
college where I went
it's the Honors College to say too
flirty everybody has to do just a thesis
yep and I wanted to do psychedelic
research but it was during the 80s when
all research was shut down in the US and
all over the world and then I started
realizing that there's something even
more important than doing new research
which is doing follow-up studies to the
old research yes and I figured here we
are in the Nancy Reagan just say no
escalation of the drug war in the 80s
and because Walter pahnke he had died he
wasn't around and nobody had thought to
do a follow-up study to the Good Friday
experiment and so I thought I can do
that because I'm not asking to give
drugs to anybody yes so I was gonna go
and ask to follow up questions yeah I'm
just gonna go talk to them and so that
led to a whole drama of how I found them
and all that but in the end I identified
19 out of the 20 who I flew all over the
country to interview that yes and what I
found for me was in some ways the key to
the
1960s and so the two things that I found
one was negative one was positive the
negative thing that I found is that they
had covered up the fact that one of the
persons who had got the psilocybin was
so inspired by Reverend Howard Thurman
and part of his sermon about telling
people that there's a man on the cross
and this is your obligation and and he
decided to tell somebody that there was
a man on the cross and he thought I'm
gonna tell the president who else should
I tell and then he realized I'm in
Boston and I'll tell the President of
the University and he left the chapel
and he went running down Commonwealth
Avenue and so Timothy Leary and Houston
Smith had to go chase him down and he
didn't want to go back indoors here he
was indoors in this Chapel now he's
outside and he's got this mission so
yeah they actually gave him a shot of
Thorazine and never reported it and so
what I discovered during this follow-up
study is that they under emphasized the
risks in a sense or the challenges yeah
they kind of talked more about the
mystical experience and not a lot about
the struggles that people went through
yes and they completely covered up this
person that they we would not have
tranquilize that person they that was
just
back in the 60s that's what they did we
don't we think that's harmful rather
than helpful okay but the other thing
that I discovered in a positive way was
that the people who had the mystical
experience reported in their lives
because of this deep sense of unity they
also this transcendence of time and
space in the sense they lost a lot of
their fear of death and they decided to
get politically engaged yeah now they
were already ministers they were already
socially justice minded but they got
involved in the anti-vietnam War
protests they got involved in the civil
rights movement they got involved in the
women's rights movement they got
involved anti makes missile base saying
they got involved in the environmental
movement and so they made a link between
their sense of unity from the mystical
experience and motivation for social
justice
so I think when people talk about the
60s most people say oh there was this
reaction to the all these psychedelics
and it was all banned because
all the problems with psychedelics but I
think the real key to the 60s is that it
was psychedelics going right that
motivated people to get involved and
challenging the status quo and that's
what led to the back in the
counterculture and to the counterculture
yeah yeah it motivated the
counterculture it scared the mainstream
culture but that there is this link
between this mystical experience whether
it's from psychedelics or any other
cause religion or meditation or fasting
or floatation tanks flotation whatever
it is and I think that's what we saw in
the 60s as people got inspired and they
challenged the status quo and Nixon like
freaks out and that's why Timothy Leary
was so for me this the first study ever
was this that I ever did was this
follow-up to the Good Friday experiment
and that kind of validated my theory of
social change as you listed all of these
different things that also lead people
to these feelings of wanting social
change because it's not just about a
psychedelic use it's also about a
floatation therapy or a meditation or
any of these other sort of ways of
feeling oneness it can even be these
longer episodes of looking into someone
else's eyes or longer you have time just
as simple as that they can catalyze the
or even withstand rough developing
holotropic breathwork he does aerobic
breath hyperventilation and this whole
world comes out what um give us a quick
bit on the whole atrophic of breath work
all right well Stan you know was the
world's leading LSD researcher and when
the backlash came he was some in the
last group in the u.s. at the Maryland
psychiatric Research Center that was
still doing LSD research but I think it
was 73 that he moved out to eslint and
became the scholar in residence and in
coast of California
yeah and Big Sur that's beautiful
beautiful spot and sort of the home of
the human potential movement and it's
still today
remarkable remarkable spot but but but a
lot of those people that were the
psychedelic researchers went into
looking at non drug catalysts because
everything else was criminalized the
small group went underground to continue
a psychedelic therapy but most people
sort of tried to figure out what are
some other ways to catalyze these
experiences that demonstrate breathwork
was one of them yes so the whole urban
breathwork stand realized that there's a
lot of these meditation techniques that
have breathing aspects to them and that
traditionally when people are agitated
and their emotions they have a like a
panic attack they start hyperventilating
it's true and and we may go to the
emergency rooms what they do is they try
to stop the hyperventilation and
suppress the symptoms and so Stan and
Christina his wife thought well what if
we let the symptoms expand what if we
encourage people to just let it all out
just screaming maybe that's a better way
than suppressing this mm-hm and so they
worked for years and then developed this
approach which they called holotropic
breathwork that involves about three or
four hours of lying down listening to
very powerful evocative music and
hyperventilating the last hour too is
more for quiet for integration very very
provoking music and then they would
practice the short breath cycles yeah
and that would maybe catalyze them to
unleash what they had as feelings within
them and then calm down at the end
during this hour or two yeah and then at
the end they may feel like oh I have
finally let go of everything yeah and
it's not so much short breaths what
standard I mean I think the brilliant
thing that he did too that he and
Christina did was to not make it too
much like certain kind of meditation
techniques like six seven times in this
nostril seven times in that you know all
these complicated things what he would
just say is breathe faster and deeper
faster and deeper and find your own yeah
yeah just keep going and you'll find
them in a few minutes things will start
to shift yeah you start losing control
of your emotions and then the
environment is there to help you lose
control to help things come to the
surface ìlet ated by professionals
yeah which is another key point of your
trials and your work that you're doing
that was this facilitation you have the
process yeah and I think the one thing
that's important to stress here when
we're talking about breath is that you
know we talked about meditation or
fasting or all these different ways that
these are experiences that are human
experiences catalyzed by all these
different things they're not like drug
experiences that are fundamentally
hallucinations or distortions they're
the property of the human mind and
emotions and that there's all these
different ways to to get into those
space I love that and and that kind of
grounds it it's kind of these are
natural experiences and you can do it
with breath all these different ways to
get there and then get a sense of
oneness within a sense of oneness of the
collective now a quick right before we
get to what's going on with maps give us
the quick bit on what happened because
the prison prison experiment that that
was after okay so there's a Concord
Prison Experiment Stanford Prison
Experiment is a different one where
people talk shows dressed up as either
prisoners or guards yeah and it showed
how people can be coerced into being
cruel just by social roles even though
they know they're making it up but the
Concord Prison Experiment in Concord is
just twenty ten miles that way okay and
so what Tim realized is that and this
was his other major experiment when he's
horrible oh up it was after the good
well it started before a little bit and
lasted till after the Good Friday
experiment and it was often mostly with
Ralph Metzner yeah and a few others but
what what Tim realized is that if people
say they have a mystical experience or
they say I'm happier now or whatever you
just have their word for it so it's
subjective in a way but he said what can
we look at that's objective and he
figured if we can work with prisoners
right before they get paroled the object
of measure is are they going back to
prison or not so the idea of the
conquered prison experiment was to help
people before they get released to have
this kind of pro-social mystical
experience then hopefully once they get
out they won't commit
crimes the same rate and recidivism is
lowered because of this yeah interest
and recidivism just you just check it
out everybody can agree yeah look they
didn't come back octave yeah and so Tim
reported this as tremendous success and
it was one what it was the percentages
well I'll see in just a second that that
everybody thought I thought that this
was one of the most important he's ever
ever in the history of psychedelic yeah
and it was tremendous success and he
showed that you could reduce recidivism
recidivism sucks because it takes away
from that person's soul it takes away
from the finances of our platform we're
trying to educate people rather than
imprison them further there's so many
things that are or that this is really
good for and then then them leaving
there's so many movements for them to be
people to know entrepreneurs after
prison there's so many of these
movements and so this is really crucial
so I wanted to do this follow-up study
to the Concord Prison Experiment because
I thought this would bring to light one
of the most important successes in
psychedelic history from the 60s but the
problem was that I didn't know who the
prisoners were yeah there was no Tim
didn't have any lists there was no way
to find out who the prisoners were yeah
so there happened to be a report I
published a paper in 1991 about the Good
Friday experiment follow-up and there
was an article in The Boston Globe about
it and then I got a call from a fella
might foresee a he said I work for the
prison system ooh and we have a special
room for the files of famous prisoners
and in that we have the files of all the
people from the Concord Prison
Experiment and then did you do a follow
well yes so it took us a year to get
permission we had well all the way up to
the governor william weld at the time
and the the piece of paper that we got
that said we could do this study was
incredible because somebody had done it
was all permission but in handwriting
somebody had said no psilocybin
administration just to clarify now of
course we were just gonna look at their
records as said and they just want to
emphasize absolutely not
so eventually we did get to do all this
we got to but then I started getting
this sickening feeling
in my stomach as I was working on this
because the numbers were not shaping up
to what Tim had reported so what I was
finding in this follow-up study was that
Tim had really twisted the data and he
had reported on it multiple times over
the years and the farther away it was
from the original experiment the better
and better the results
he claimed that they were and what I was
able to find then he start saying well
at one point early on he said well they
didn't have reduced recidivism but they
were went back to prison for more minor
things like parole violations rather
than new cries okay so I'm sorting
through this and I'm jetting off to
hammer out all the nuance of it yeah
well then it turns out that he
completely fudged it complete aah and
that people had gone back to prison for
parole violations but that's because
they had committed new crimes yeah and
they were violated on other things and
then they were convicted of those crimes
so I could watch so and also the single
episode is very difficult to give people
to this pro-social well they would have
several administration's too but what I
also discovered was that near the so
Timothy Leary got and Ronis they get
kicked out and I think yeah yeah so they
got kicked out in 63 but they started
realizing that just like with drug abuse
treatment you need support afterwards
like with ibogaine all the people that
get I began but then if they go back to
the same environment correct yeah so
they started a support group for the
prisoners after they got out yes
and then that fell apart after they got
kicked out of Harvard so I think my
conclusion of this is first off that Tim
left science behind and became popular
as AI popularizer yeah but I think he
saw so much wrong information
exaggerating the risks that he felt
justified to exaggerate the benefits and
you bring up that key point of community
through this process and that same thing
applies to us working with homeless
relations yes communities after you go
and onto parole what are the communities
of people that help you stay out yeah
yeah so my conclusion would be that we
need to go back and replicate that
experiment and do work with people
before they get paroled and that that
can be extremely helpful to work on
their trauma work on all of their
emotional problems and then though once
they get out we need more support groups
yep and then I think we probably will be
able to reduce recidivism yep but it was
very difficult for me to be the one
who's an advocate for psychedelics to
have to expose what the world thought of
as one of the best experiments ever and
to show that it was not done the results
were not interpreted do you have a lot
more work to do to make sure that they
are interpret to that we do the right
job along the way okay now let's break
down Maps can you give us the breakdown
in terms of the number one because right
now you psycho so psychedelics and
cannabis both so then we're looking at
is it MDMA first and then psilocybin and
then LSD and then cannabis or what's
this breakdown
well maps and there's other groups off
there are other groups one called you
Sona and one called the compass pathways
so that are trying to develop psilocybin
into a message a medicine for depression
the compass is a for-profit company
based in England and Ozona is a
non-profit based in Madison Wisconsin so
they're doing suicide and you're no
we're not okay no it's just there so I
mean to make a drug through a medicine
oh gosh so obligated and so we've sort
of focused on MDMA is our top priority
with marijuana as our second and no LSD
well we did fund the first LSD study in
like 40 years okay but we have had to
for strategic reasons because we don't
have unlimited resources although a
non-profit some nonprofit if somebody
wanted to donate more we would be
restart the LSD I mean we just had April
19th was the 75th anniversary of the
discovery of LSD and there is studies in
Switzerland being done looked at LSD for
anxiety yeah but but we have realized
that that we have to concentrate and
it's
you may assisted psychotherapy for PTSD
and today is a tremendous day yeah very
fortuitous that you guys have come by
today so we got a paper published in
Lancet psychiatry that is about one of
our phase two studies that was in
veterans firefighters and police
officers with chronic
treatment-resistant PTSD and we got
absolutely great results you know we
just watched the coverage on Fox News
you know it's in the New York Times it's
the American Psychiatric Association
daily newsletter at the top key thing
for today is our MDMA study it's been on
CNN it's been in all the military comm
websites and military sites so even Fox
was playfully talking about the
importance of this it was shocked
shocking shocking to me but it's because
of the veterans yes I think that they
care more about veterans and PTSD and
everybody fire from Fox
these officers people bus yeah yeah well
so this is where what I learned at the
Kennedy School government so yeah where
I got my masters in PhD and regulation
of thematically used to schedule one so
I also learned a lot about politics and
so in sort of the psychedelic science we
have to pick which drugs which patient
populations which conditions and so we
need to do we need to Blake break down
the US and them because this was culture
counterculture we need to in a sense
show that it's helpful to them to the
mainstream culture so we knew there's
massive crisis with veterans in PTSD yes
but I thought just for political reasons
we'll say that the study is for veterans
firefighters and police officers I
didn't think we'd get any veterans I
mean I didn't think we'd get any
firefighters or police officers but in
the end we did we got one one police
officer and three firefighters and 22
veterans yes so and we got tremendous
tremendous results can you tell us oh
yeah so base to this is phase two what
does that mean well so let's start so
good you you begin with usually you'd be
in what are called non clinical studies
which are animal studies and trying to
figure out the toxicity of the drug and
what it might do physiologically how it
might be helpful then you go into humans
and that's called phase one and phase
one are usually healthy volunteers dose
response safety studies we're again
you're trying to see what are the side
effects maybe you get some clue as to
the effects if it's a very dangerous
drug like cancer chemotherapy drugs
it's called combination phase one phase
two where you bring in actual patients
because the risks the non patients would
be too great but then then you move to
Phase three and those are the
large-scale multi-site studies that are
meant to be the definitive studies to
prove safety and efficacy to get
permission to market a drug as a
prescription medicine there's also
what's called phase four studies and so
the FDA can require additional research
after the drug is approved so for
example the FDA is requiring us to do
work in adolescents with PTSD because
many many drugs are studied in adults
but they're never studied in kids and
they're prescribed off-label for kids
but therapists and physicians they don't
know the dose they don't know if it'll
really work there's all sorts of things
so the FDA is now more and more
requiring pharmaceutical companies and
in this case maps as a nonprofit were
being treated the same way so we're
being required to do a study in 12 to 17
year olds with PTSD who have failed on
other treatments but that's a phase four
study after a drug is approved okay
right so what we did
Maps got started in 86 it took us till
92 took us six years to get permission
for the first phase one safety study Wow
yeah and that took years to do and then
it wasn't until 2000 1999 and 2000 that
we got permission for the first phase to
study which was MDMA for post-traumatic
stress disorder and that was done in
Spain and unfortunately we had very good
results and there was good media and the
early stages of the study that alerted
the Madrid anti-drug Authority and they
shut the study down for political
reasons
it was super frustrating so but then we
were able in 2000
for to start the first study in the US
and that study was mostly women
survivors of childhood sexual abuse and
adult rape and assault so it was almost
entirely women in this first study and
the results were outstanding
so roughly 83% of them no longer had
PTSD and this was how many was the
sample size this was 21 21 and this is
administered over how long this is about
a three and a half month process with
the three MDMA sessions one month apart
and twelve 90-minute non drug
psychotherapy sessions well you have
three before the first MDMA session okay
then three for preparation and then
three after each MDMA session for
integration Wow then two months after
the last MDMA session is what's called
the primary outcome measure that's what
the FDA is going to consider and then
there's a 12-month follow-up and
sometimes we do even longer it's not
sort of approval that's more for the 18
of them are so said that they did not
feel like they well they didn't so much
say it is that there's a hour-long
interview developed by the Veterans
Administration called the clinician
administered PTSD scale or the cows and
that's how us yes even today we're even
today yeah it's it's the gold standard
all over the world it was used to
approve zoloft and paxil for PTSD it's
the measure that the FDA walls okay and
so they reported on the caps to these
independent raters who didn't know were
they in the MDMA group were they in the
placebo group so one group would go
through this with therapy and get a pill
that would be an inactive placebo and
the other would go through it and get
one do you may so everybody got the
therapy but what buried was what's in
the bill yeah and so then we realized
that it was important for us to start
working with veterans because that means
only 11 well well it's a little bit more
complicated you're right about that so
well you don't always have to do 50/50
okay so we did we did 13 and 813 unit 13
got MDMA and the placebo but what we do
is everybody in the placebo group once
we have this blinded pilot of this
two-month primary outcome measure then
everybody that's in the placebo group
can go through it again open label means
they are all
gonna get MDMA so the 83% is either the
people that went through it so what we
were able to show is that by looking at
how the people did with therapy and then
how well they did when we added MDMA
that roughly forty percent of the
benefit is from the therapy and sixty
percent is from the drug okay which is
really good because that means is that
most of it is from the drug yeah and so
we can have a wide range of skills in
the therapists and people are still
likely to get better and also people can
heal themselves we hear them too these
stories about people that took them do
you may at a rave and they remember
trauma and they were able to work
through it or we have terrible stories
of people that took MDMA at a rape
remember trauma and they're with friends
who just want a party party and then
they try to stuff their feelings down
and they are worse off for months
afterwards yeah so it's not the drug
it's the drug assistance psychotherapy
and being willing to process it yeah
and so the willingness to process and so
what we've done so far is a hundred and
seven patients in all six different
studies since 92 since well the 92 one
doesn't count because that's that's not
PTSD patients but yeah so there's an
additional 28 patients from that study
okay and that's part of our safety
database but 107 of PTSD patients with
god MDMA okay and November 29 2016 we
had a meeting with the FDA which is
called an end of phase 2 meeting that's
where you present your data safety and
efficacy and say we want to go to the
big time we want to go to Phase three
and make it into a medicine yes and the
FDA said yes we clicked and then they
have a new program relatively new that's
called special protocol assessment and
you can voluntarily engage in this
special protocol assessment and what
happens is that you negotiate every
aspect of your design with the FDA and a
lot of pharmaceutical companies don't
like to do it because it delays things
six to 12 months and they've got a
patent and they're trying to get it
approved and they're not doing anything
very controversial are very complex from
a scientific methodological point but we
are doing both controversial and complex
because how do you do a double-blind
you know if you've taken the drugs that
so we went through this special protocol
assessment and 28th of July of 2017 we
reached agreement great all right and
then the big thing is that we also so
that was the most important program of
the FTA because now they are legally
bound to approve the drug if that design
gets statistically significant evidence
of efficacy and no new safety problems
come up and it's unlike a new drug where
you know drugs that pharmaceutical
companies are tested in a few thousand
people then you let it loose and you see
the one and a hundred thousand side
effect but you know tens and tens and
tens of millions people have taken MDMA
ecstasy for decades and decades so we
know the safety profile so that's
something manufactured last year yeah
who knows what's in it knows what's in
it yeah yeah so so then what we said is
the most the most visible program the
FDA has is called breakthrough therapy
we're here and so two-thirds of the
applications from big pharma for
breakthrough therapy for their drugs are
rejected so it's really just for drugs
for serious or life-threatening
illnesses for which there's a large
population of people that don't get
relief from the currently available
drugs and your preliminary phase two
evidence or preliminary evidence phase
one suggests that this could be a
breakthrough for them cool so I was a
little bit concerned under President
Trump and under attorney General
Sessions with FDA be willing to be so
public about their support and their
promise of MDMA research yeah and so
August 15th they said yes we have
breakthrough therapy designation so
that's going to help us get it approved
we have more meetings with the FDA
they're now partnering with us and
trying to make it through the system
amazing all right so what we're doing
right now and then I should say over the
last few months starting in December to
March an astonishing thing happened is
we raised over ten million dollars yeah
and it was because of Mr Pyne we think
it's mr. but it's pine from the
pineapple fund and said a crypto fund
yes so so what happened is this guy
pine all we know is pine we had
borderline personality disorder and was
depressed and so he was looking for
treatment
and he decided that he would try
ketamine treatment Jack's at this point
he had not heard about maps he had no
idea about maps so under the influence
of ketamine he has this vision and the
vision is that the way for him to start
feeling better and to get out of these
loops of depression and borderline
personality is to help other people yeah
that helping other people is sort of the
key and he decided that he had made so
much money in Bitcoin that he would give
away eighty six million dollars worth of
bitcoins and he put a little notice in
reddit just a paragraph or two multiple
people sent in saw it immediately and
sent a map supply for this yeah and we
had then one of her staff submitted a
one-page application wow this is even
before I even heard of haha so Wow
people are emailing staff they spend one
page up you have a great team we do a
fantastic team so then the next day we
got an email from pine saying I'm giving
you a million dollars and two hours
later they showed up the Bitcoin showed
up in our wallet Wow then he said I
might be willing to give you a matching
grant so we talked about that for a
while and then he gave us a four million
dollar matching grant that was expiring
March 10th from January 10th to March
10th and so we were able to use that to
get four million dollars from other
people 1 million of which was also in
bitcoins we also got a million dollars
from bitcoins from somebody we don't
even know who it is
yeah and then we got three quarters of a
million from another cryptocurrency coin
called the loon which is used for like
what they want to do is kind of a
Wikipedia where you pay the authors in
these loons and ads and we're competing
with that anyway we got all these
donations so we have now shockingly been
able to raise twenty six million dollars
hell yes yeah five million from dr.
Bronner's Shawna Halley who was a tech
wizard who was on our board of directors
who died 2012 and left us five and half
million in his will that we saved two
and a half million from good ventures
which was an early Facebook yeah person
is giving us that money but any case we
have this war chest of 26 million
dollars and it's it was in October right
before this started happening that I
realized that the nationalist and mental
health
and the Department of Defense and the VA
we're not going to give us a penny even
though FDA it said it's a breakthrough
even though they have a massive problem
with PTSD yeah but well it's the stigma
of these drugs yeah it seems like the VA
is stigma of the drugs just doesn't
there's a reason also on top of money
it's about the persecution of minorities
I mean if we look at you know look at
Florida where Bush got elected and where
which went for Trump and they have
arrested loads and loads of
african-americans who tend to vote
Democratic and once you get a felony
arrest then you can't vote in Florida
are you so it's called felony
disenfranchisement yeah so the war on
drugs is a tool of politics to make it
so that the Republicans win Democrats a
lot of them didn't realize that until
too late yeah but but in any case
there's this whole problem where we
realize that we're not gonna get any
support from the official world yeah and
then I started thinking okay well in a
way I'm glad it's been 30 plus years but
you haven't this far without it yeah so
now we'll be able to say that it's a
gift to the world MDMA is a gift to the
world from the psychedelic community but
now I have to say that it's a gift to
the world from the psychedelic and
cryptocurrency and so what we're doing
right now is working with the final step
of training the therapists and so we've
got a protocol that the therapists that
we've trained 84 therapists 42
male-female killer P teams and they're
each getting a patient with PTSD to work
with in open-label
which means again everybody knows
they're getting MDMA it won't count for
efficacy because not card up part of a
controlled study and so we're in the
final stages of training the therapist
at 16 sites there - in Israel - in
Canada and the rest in the u.s. is good
and so this summer we're starting phase
3 and we think by 2021
we'll have MDMA approved as a
prescription that's amazing right so the
other thing before we run out of light
out here I'll just say that we're also
doing the only study in America
with marijuana for PTSD yeah it's it's
the only marijuana drug development
study for any reason under way in the
United States there are studies by GW
Pharmaceuticals with CBD extract Jim
that's for childhood epilepsy and
they're gonna get approved they just had
their FDA advisory committee but we're
the only ones working with the plant and
it's with 76 veterans with chronic
treatment-resistant PTSD it's taking
place with dr. sue Sisley in Phoenix
Arizona great and we got 2 point 1
million dollars from the state of
Colorado amazing so they've made roughly
500 million dollars in marijuana taxes
they did about 10 million for research
perfect and we got to 21 million so
that's our first government grant ever
but it's a state government so we've now
enrolled 56 of 76 veterans the Phoenix
VA is refusing to refer subjects again
stigma and Prejudice we're gonna get
enough subjects there anyway and then
the big issue and this is what we're
also working on with marijuana is how do
you make marijuana into a medicine
because right now for the last 50 years
since 1968 there's only one source of
marijuana that's grown under DEA license
that federally legal that can be used in
FDA approved studies and that's grown at
the University of Mississippi under
contract to the National ensign drug
abuse and they can provide for research
but they cannot provide a commercial
medicine and so phase 3 which I've
decided to described as the major
studies they have to be done with the
exact same drug that you want to market
so because NIDA Marijuana can not be
marketed we cannot move to Phase three
so since 1999 in 2000 we've been trying
to break this monopoly and as of August
12 2011 it's holding us back
massively and there was just an
incredible article in Businessweek
Bloomberg Businessweek that said America
is giving away the 30 billion dollar
medical marijuana industry you know
because there's Canadian companies
British companies Israeli companies
correct Dutch companies but not any
federally legal US come exactly giving
it a
it's stupid stupid and it's a jobs
program so we're trying to sell trucks
this is about job in a health no this
yeah and this will reduce health care
class because marijuana is cheap
compared all these pharmaceutical drugs
that it will replace yes sir which is
another one of the things potentially
holding ya back yeah so so what we're
are we okay yeah what's up we're back
inside now after the great hot tub
session dried off and we're ready to
continue it with a conversation yeah so
where I was that was saying that this of
government monopoly on marijuana is
something that's essential that we break
and it's been kept protected by the DEA
because they have not wanted good
research about benefits of marijuana to
take place but we've worked on this a
long time in 2005 we had a lawsuit
against the DEA and we won the lawsuit
in 2007 the DEA administrative law judge
said it would be in the public interest
for us to get a license to grow
marijuana
we were working actually with Professor
Lyle Kraker at UMass Amherst but the DEA
just like with an MDMA situation the
head of the DEA rejected the
recommendation but they waited almost
two years before they did anything and
they five days before Obama took office
they rejected the recommendation just to
screw it up so that he wouldn't face
this fresh and so it took a while into
his second term but August 12 2016 DEA
finally said that they would end the
monopoly and since then 26 or so people
have applied for licenses but then we
got trump and then we've got sessions
and sessions has been blocking the DEA
are you but recently he's under a lot of
pressure from different senators as we
get more medical marijuana like slovak
washington state oh my god so well
Camilla Harris Orrin Hatch is actually
one of the main Republican senators is
one of the main advocates for ending the
monopolies Wow Camilla Harris the
senator from California senator schatz
from Hawaii senator gillibrand from New
York senator Earl Warren Elizabeth
Warren from Massachusetts so there's
more and more pressure and they realized
that
this business is growing that we are
giving it away to the world correct and
so yeah a lot of smart people here that
should be researching this getting
better at helping people with this yeah
and all of the state marijuana they're
producing way better quality than the
government can provide but none of it is
federally legal so we can't use any of
it in FDA research so that's our big
thing is to try to break the monopoly
and then if we get good results from
this marijuana PTSD study and veterans
you know then we'll expand it and one of
the interesting things for those of your
viewers from Michigan is that there's
going to be a marijuana legalization
initiative on the ballot in November in
Michigan and the way it was written it
was written by some friends of ours they
put in their 20 million dollars a year
for two years for research into cannabis
for veterans to help reduce suicides
perfect so if the Michigan legalization
initiative passes eventually there'll be
loads of money for making the plant and
so our goal is to take the plant in bud
flower form and make it into a medicine
either smoked or vaporized there's I
think that's the wind
okay there's there's loads and loads of
companies for profit that are going to
take the marijuana plant
slice and dice it extracts and
non-smoking delivery systems that they
patent and all that's good and all that
should move forward because that
provides important tools but what we
want to do is have generic buds
available at very low cost and then
there'll be a little bit of a check on
the prices that other people could
charge for all their other stuff but I'm
flying with for-profit drug development
and we will cooperate with them share
what we know but but we want to take the
bud and in Israel right now they grow
very good high potency buds trim two
buds for 60 cents a gram which is about
fourteen dollars an ounce super duper
high potency buds so it's going to be a
very inexpensive medicine yeah and I
think that's what as a non-profit we're
hearing more about public health and
course making loads money and that's the
Oceaneer that
that's what we want to do marijuana so
now I'm I'm hearing that we're
approaching this era of this
collaboration or this competition a
little bit yeah and we so we're doing
this with cannabis this is happening
with psychedelics now with psilocybin we
were mentioning these two organizations
sauna sauna sauna
a new sauna you so not encompass yeah
okay and so then there's what we just
described with Mississippi having this
monopoly yeah and versus being able to
take cannabis for the for the for the
better for research and give it for
people's health and test it research
doing all this across the u.s. and the
world so this conversation happens a lot
on simulation we talk a lot about
globalization we talk a lot about
collaboration and how to not exacerbate
wealth inequality how to not yeah how to
not exacerbate or hiccups that we might
have with the proliferation of
artificial intelligence the
proliferation was bio warfare
over-regulation and things like that
we're profiteering rather than focusing
on people's health and so this leads us
into this discussion point which is how
are we going to as companies want to
figure out how to innovate and fund lots
of dollars in innovation and then they
want to you know patent their
innovations and their processes but at
the same time you don't want to inhibit
other people from just picking
psilocybin right from the from the
forests and are using it you don't want
to embrace in them for yes so how do we
figure this I think you put your hair
and one of the more complicated issues
that sort of split the psychedelic
research community so you're basically
talking about legalization how do we
make it so people can have access to
these drugs for their own benefit
religious or recreational even or
therapeutic without having to go through
a pharmaceutical company and a doctor or
without having to go through a religion
and so I think that is the long-term
goal is to make it so that we look at
prohibition and see it as a system of
repression against minorities in
particular political minorities or
african-americans or Mexicans or Chinese
or the whole history of prohibition in
the u.s. that we move to a public health
approach but I think the before that
this question of how medicalization
leads to legalization that's what we've
seen with medical marijuana yeah that's
what's changed people's attitudes
towards legalization of marijuana so I
think we have to medicalize psychedelics
and then we'll get to this point but
then how do we medical eyes and that's
where there is also this competition or
cooperation so I think that for-profit
drug development is fine I think that
you do have you know wrong incentives a
lot of times and so when what maps has
done you know a lot of times people say
I'm I don't think marijuana should be
illegal I don't want people going to
jail for it but I don't want big alcohol
and Big Tobacco Big Pharma to start
selling marijuana and they'll sell it to
kids and they'll don't sell it to have
users and they don't care if it's
addictive or they won't and they'll add
chemicals to it as well it won't remain
organic that's the tip the cigarettes
that I smoke it's not tobacco it's the
drugs that keep me back yeah coming back
for ten bucks a day hmm sorry and so
what we've done is we're trying to not
just pioneer new treatments with
psychedelics in marijuana but a new way
to sell pharmaceuticals so we've created
what we think is the maybe it's the only
public benefit corporation in the
pharmaceutical space there are other
nonprofit pharmaceutical companies
though so but they tend to develop drugs
and then they sell it off to some other
for-profit company to market so what we
have is the maps public benefit
corporation that is maximizing public
benefit not profits to sell MDMA you
know it's a for-profit company because
we need to pay taxes on the income from
MDMA but it has only one investor in the
maps public benefit which is the
nonprofit's nonprofit controls the
for-profit that's what will sell MDMA
that's what's doing our research will
fund the research yeah yeah and then
whatever profits we make from you
we'll find more research it doesn't have
to stick with them do you make it fun
LSD research so that's how we're
structured that seems to be the seed
that's structured in a very ethical way
yeah and that's what we love and that's
what we want to hear more of and we
don't know some seeds are not structured
that ethical way it sounds like that's
starting to happen a little bit well I
think that for profit can be ethical as
well and there's just a general
suspicion of pharmaceutical companies
that's totally justified based on the
way they've performed but they don't
have to perform that way so I think
there's another issue which is people
are suffering there are millions and
millions of people with depression so
the fact that compass has decided to try
to work with investors to make
psilocybin into a medicine for
depression and USANA is working with
donors to make it into a medicine
we're helping both of them so we're
cooperating with both and I think both
are legitimate and I think there's a
little bit of a difference in what how
they're approaching it from a business
point of view what compass is trying to
do is to use the minimum to get it at
the minimum amount of cost to help the
most people and so in a way that made up
reducing therapists reducing therapist
hours trying to have the drug do as much
of it as possible and there's dangers
there you can just say hey here's like
what's being done that with ketamine for
depression it works for a lot of people
but it would I think and many people
think it might be more effective if it
were combined with psychotherapy
definitely but people are just saying oh
here's ketamine and you know and then
you were off on your own there's not
help to integrate it and there's not
that much help to prepare for it but we
see pine who had his experience under
ketamine that inspired him to support
maps and he said one of the things he
realized is that when he was under the
influence of ketamine he wished that he
would have had support from a therapist
yeah and the fact that we're talking
about mdma-assisted psychotherapy made
him feel more comfortable but the point
is we are willing to cooperate with
anybody that is trying to make these
drugs into medicines whether they're for
profit or not
and I think that both can be done
ethically you know you can have an
unethical nonprofit where you pay
yourself millions of dollars worth of
salaries and you buy how your your
family and you you know you you know so
it's more about the Board of Directors
and what's what's the purpose of it why
and and we've got this whole way so far
with only donors no ambassadors yeah
we're in a really good shape exactly
yeah
yeah and that's very similar to what
we're doing with our studio space and
our creative incubating effort is that
we're sustaining off of patreon off of
the service for creators and artists
that get paid every month by people I
believe in them yeah and that way you
know same thing where you can totally
take of the creative effort of this
community and see where it goes together
with that so yeah we're talking about
the seed and the importance of the
ethics behind the seed and then you said
it there are many people that are
working a for-profit to decrease the
cost as much as possible so that they
can give it to people should there also
be psychotherapy combined with that
what's the efficacy of that see this is
gonna be these next coming conversations
it's gonna be really exciting really
interesting and phase three is come
moving forward with MDMA and pts deeds
now you were on talking about on Fox
News is amazing yeah so we're really
grateful to have this opportunity to sit
down together yeah Rick I want to ask
you a couple quick questions that we
typically ask on a simulation on the
show I want to ask you first
what's the deepest emotion you've ever
felt well well okay well I mean I'm you
know so I'll describe this was this was
what prepared me I would say to get
married and so this was an experience in
1985 there's a couple years before I met
my wife but it was an MDMA experience
and I was camping out by myself doing
MDMA all night
and I was trying in a way to think about
the DEA how do I as I'm getting more
public how do I stay safe that is a part
of it was that a saloon at Big Sur so I
was camping out so the mountains go
right down to the water of a camping
down right there there's a place where I
found where the high tide came within a
few feet there was this little space
that the high tide wouldn't get to
because of boulders out in the ocean so
this is a protected spot with the
roaring of the ocean and there was a
little freshwater creek running by and
so I was kind of alone in the universe
this enormous universe with the roaring
of the massive Pacific Ocean and but I
was also thinking about brother David
Stein de Rossi who was a very
inspirational person for me and he was a
Roman Catholic monk mystic ecumenical
but he was willing to do MDMA and had
done MDMA in the monastery to help him
meditate and found that it was useful
and it was even willing to be public
about it he was in the first art so I
was trying to think why would somebody
want to celibate life I was at this
point without a girlfriend between
relationships and I was just sort of
thinking how do I stay safe from the DEA
and I don't think about what's what's
the value of a monastic life so anyway I
focus a lot on your mission and your
values and making the world better
yeah and that's very interesting that
you even bring that up because I think
many people get pushed by their genetics
into procreation yeah and and so they
they put their sometimes their impact on
the world second to having a family or
they try and combine them somehow which
is also very good but but to just do
this whole celibate life for the greater
good of humanity's mind blow and I was
just trying to sort it out like what was
in it for him and so it was in the
middle of the night and I had this this
one moment where I felt yeah the
universe is just so enormous leave asked
and the stars are just so knowing that
the pounding of the ocean and stuff and
just you know and I felt like I'm so
tiny in this vast universe that I might
just disappear you know and there was a
little bit of fear like I would just
disappear into the universe
and at some point I realized that I
hadn't disappeared and then I started
thinking well why am I not flying off
into the universe and I started thinking
about gravity the gravity was kind of
holding my molecules together
he was molding me there and then I had
this image of gravity like love that
pulled things together and then I felt
like I was being cradled in the arms of
gravity like gravity was a lover and I
was in the arms of a lover being cradled
and it felt this enormous sense of
connection to the universe to the loving
nature of the universe yeah and and that
image of just being cradled in the arms
of gravity yes and I I felt like then
that I was always in touch with this
possibility of love whether I had lover
or not yeah it was what from the
universe and that that is what the
monastic life is supposed to help you
get to Wow you don't connect to
particular lovers or families but you
sort of have this Universal Universal I
want to love her too I decided not to go
for the self at life you'd want to share
that with that understanding you want to
share that you want to give back and you
can't give it back to the universe but
yeah I hear you yeah that's a good one
cradled by the universe cradled by the
arms of gravity gravity yeah because
you're so aware of existence and then
that helps you really feel the love
within you of the cosmos and then also
enables you to give love out from you
okay and then how about since we are
speaking about the cosmos mm-hmm do you
think we're alone in the cosmos well I
mean it's hard to believe that we're
lone I mean it's so vast how could it be
that we're alone do I believe that
there's been visitors from outer space
that are here if not necess
do you think advanced civilizations are
roaming the cosmos possibly I don't know
I mean look at it this way we're about
to destroy the planet
we could easily through environmentalism
through through disregard of the
environment we've got all these
incredible technologies Einstein said
that our technology has exceeded our
humanity yeah so maybe there are no more
advanced civilizations maybe they've
also self-destructed correct and you
know whether we're gonna self-destruct
or not is not clear yeah whether we're
gonna survive or not so it's a first so
I think that the question really is does
it matter if there were people from
outer space if there were you know what
would I do differently so I think that's
really then how I've wrestled with do I
need to find out if there was you know
do I need to start looking at UFO
literature so you know if somebody from
an outer space landed and that would I
do anything differently I'm doing
whatever I can the best I can
yes to try to help people cope with the
challenges of protecting the species
protecting the planet for taking the
other species so I wouldn't do anything
differently I'm doing exactly what I
want to be doing what I think is the
most important so whether there are
spirits out there or not I don't know I
was just actually asked to write a blurb
for a book there's a group of people
that got together to talk about
experiences under the influence of DMT
where do you have this experience of
some alien intelligence is it really a
lian's what is it you know of course
they did not resolve it to be certain is
a mistake it's just a mystery and I can
easily believe that there's other
intelligences and hopefully our senses
get augmented to the point where we can
explore past the 3d and figure it out so
yeah
cosmic siblings let's find them I care a
lot about that I care a lot about
figuring out the history of the cosmos
and where these dirty filters happened
okay how about do you think we're in a
computer simulation again the same
question is does it matter
I mean thing
matter you know people seem to either
experience pleasure or pain I experience
pleasure of aim it feels real so whether
it's a computer simulation or not who
cares awesome and then maybe we do what
is the most beautiful thing in the world
well I've heard this that for men the
most beautiful thing in the world is a
naked woman and for women it's a baby
which reminds me of a poem of EE
Cummings my favorite Cummings poems very
short let's see a pretty woman who naked
is is worth a million statues awesome
been such a pleasure because public
education is absolutely crucial I mean
we're doing the research but we've got
to get the word out gotta get the word
out and there's so many layers to what
we unpacked today yeah everybody thank
you so much for tuning in if you guys
found this content to be useful
definitely give it a share share it with
other people around you let's get more
word out about the importance of
psychedelics and what they can do for
humanity and what they have been doing
for so long and really get this in the
hands of researchers and practitioners
and healing and he if you want more
information maps and ApS maps org in the
bio as well yeah and if you want to
donate we would be grateful absolutely
and it's really important again share
links in and B in the bio join us in the
donation as well give the content a like
comment below let us know your thoughts
give us a subscribe join the community
join us on patreon we need to continue
supporting the sustainability of this
project so we can bring all of the
goodness across all these fields to you
and thank you very much for tuning in
and we'll catch you guys soon thank you